well Jimmy Kimmel is back and he brought
his baby and he used his baby for a
political prop and we'll talk about it
plus it is down to the wire in Alabama
Roy Moore rides it on a horse yes
literally to vote in Alabama today Plus
president Trump may have a better case
today against the molar investigation
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
so I was just remarking to Malthus
before the program that all of life
should now be scored to yakety sax from
Benny Hill because everything is
ridiculous and it gets more and more
ridiculous each and every day we're
gonna talk at length about Jimmy Kimmel
who brought his baby again to use as a
political prop again I hate this again
so much again I will discuss all chance
I'm going to break it down for a no no
no not at night wait on it just wait
we'll get there but we're gonna get to
that we also get to Roy Moore who had a
very interesting close of the campaign
last night his wife got on stage and
talked about the Jews so we'll talk
about that and whether she was in fact
being anti-semitic not really but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Bull and branch so as I have
said before sleep and I are not friends
however bowl and branch is helping to
cure that problem because bowl and
branch sheets they are the best sheets I
sleep better at home that I do at a
hotel not just because I'm at home but
also because the sheets on my bed are of
top-notch quality Bowl and bran sheets
are breathable they are crafted from
100% organic cotton
that means they not only feel incredible
they also look terrific they are sold
exclusively online so you don't pay that
expensive retail markup half the price
twice the quality man you can try them
for 30 nights and see for yourself
you're not impressed you can return them
for a full refund anyone who sleeps on
these sheets loves them that is why they
have thousands of five-star reviews I am
among the people who review this with
five stars really the sheets are
terrific go to bull and branch calm
today you will get $50 off your first
set of sheets plus free shipping when
you use promo code Ben bull and branch
combi ll and branch com promo code Ben
you get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets Plus free shipping again bull and
branch com promo code Ben check it out
and you will be sleeping better by
tomorrow okay so we begin with Jimmy
Kimmel so Jimmy Kimmel trotted out his
child again last night
and I hate this more than I can tell you
when people do this hey I can safely say
because it has been scientifically
verified that I have the two cutest
children on planet Earth in fact I have
a child of three and a half years a girl
three and a half years old who is so
cute date last night
she actually started doing lines from
the room and no I'm not kidding she is
amazing but she also happened to have a
heart condition she had an open heart
surgery that was performed at the same
but all by the same doctor is jimmy
kimmel son and yet i do not routinely
trot out my daughter's stories whenever
i talk about health care what i'm
talking about Obamacare policy i don't
say and i know about this because my
daughter had her chest cut open because
they had to fix an ASD a hole in her
heart I don't do that because it's
stupid I don't do that because I don't
think that there's virtue in victimhood
I don't think that just because
something bad happened to you in life
that means that now you know more about
that thing than anyone else I think that
this this reference to personal
experience when it comes to policy
matters is actually the end of policy
because the reality is it's it's very
watered down form of identity politics
the reality is that politics is based on
the idea that I can talk about ideas and
you can talk about ideas because we can
sympathize with one another because we
can think what it would be like to walk
in one another's shoes without actually
having walked in those shoes if talk
about healthcare is restricted to only
those who've used the healthcare system
if talked about about about financial
systems is restricted to only those who
have worked in the financial system then
pretty quickly we are going to come to
the end of politics we can all have
opinions on matters of public policy
specifically because we have the
capacity as independent human beings to
think about what all of these things
mean for us and for others right the way
the politics is done is by shaping
policy around what we would think it
would be like to be another person we
don't actually have to have experience
that thing right you don't have to have
actually experienced the Holocaust in
order to think the Holocaust was bad you
don't actually have to have experienced
homophobia in order to think homophobia
is bad you don't have to have
experienced racism in order to think
that racism is bad all right all of
these things we can think about and come
to moral conclusions about without
actually having personally experienced
them this is one of the reasons why I
really dislike what Jimmy Kimmel does
whenever he brings out his child to talk
about healthcare policy so here's his
unsuspecting kid as his unsuspecting kid
had a second surgery last week I guess
he has one more when he's age six and
then he has done for life we can hope
and pray so Kimmel brings out his kid to
talk about the Children's Health
Insurance Program so children's health
insurance program is basically a
supplemental health insurance program
for kids who are poor and parents who
cannot take care of those kids properly
medically speaking it was sponsored
originally by Orrin Hatch for public
from Utah in the Senate in 1997
Republicans have been continuously
funding it ever since so have Democrats
and now there's a bit of a hold up in
terms of final funding for the chip
program but that is not because
Republicans are uncaring or unfeeling
yet that is what Kimmel says so Kimmel
brings out his kids to talk about chip
what does this kid have to do with chip
the answer is nothing
risky it has nothing to do with chip
right his kid is not on chip the fact is
the Jimmy Kimmel is a very very wealthy
man he has health insurance I am sure
through ABC but Jimmy Kimmel brings out
his child and he starts talking about
chip because for some reason the
experience of his child connects with
with chip in some way but you don't have
to show me a sick child in order for you
to make the case for chip whether it's
good public policy or bad public policy
but that's just with Jimmy Kimmel does
so here is Jimmy Kimmel jumping right in
and talking about Hawaii
his son surgery links up to healthcare
policy for poor people who are not him
or something chip is the Children's
Health Insurance Program it covers
around it comes around nine million
American kids whose parents make too
much money to qualify for Medicaid but
don't have access to coverage affordable
coverage that are jobs which means it
almost certainly covers children you
know about one in eight children are
covered only by chip and it's not
controversial it's not a partisan thing
fact the last time funding for chip was
authorized was in 2015 it passed with a
vote of 392 to 337 in the house and 92
to 8 in the Senate overwhelmingly
Democrats and Republicans supported it
until now now chip has become a
bargaining chip it's on the back burner
while they work out their new tax plans
which means parents of children with
cancer and diabetes and heart problems
are about to get letters saying their
coverage could be cut off next month
Merry Christmas right oh those evil
Republicans Merry Christmas on he talks
about how tax cuts are the real problem
with this right he says they let this
money expire while they work on getting
tax cut for their millionaire and
billionaire donors okay so this is this
is the shtick that Jimmy Kimmel is
pushing right now by the way they
so-called tax cuts for the millionaire
and billionaire donors okay we talked
yesterday about how the Senate botched
the bill if you make over six hundred
fifteen thousand dollars and you're
self-employed and you have like a kid
there's a good shot you're actually pay
more
taxes then you will makin money above a
certain amounts of money if you live in
a high tax state like California or New
Jersey but Jimmy Kimmel doesn't note
he's talking about and this is the
problem right everyone is sitting here
and the visuals matter so you're sitting
here and you are watching his very cute
child and that is a very cute child
right it's an adorable kid and you feel
terrible for that adorable kid as well
you should write I know I've been in
this situation I know what it's like to
have an adorable child who's had to be
cut open I get it
okay but what he's saying is pure
nonsense here okay what he is saying is
not factually correct
okay the House passed legislation last
month to fund chip for five more years
Democrats opposed it
Democrats opposed it on the grounds they
didn't like its funding mechanism it
passed the house anyway the Senate
Finance Committee passed a version of
that bill too they haven't figured out
the offsets from funding it why do they
need the offsets from funding it
they need the offsets from funding it
because in order for them to pass it
through the Senate without it being
filibustered you have to show that it's
not going to add to the deficit okay so
the Senate already is considering
pushing it President Trump last week
last week signed funding for chip that
will take it all the way through the end
of January 31st funded by the Centers
for Medicare and Medicaid Services that
federal agency has been signing checks
to States for the last two months chip
is not going unfunded senator hatch
again the original sponsor of the chip
program has pushed forward the Kids Act
reauthorizing chip for another five
years as well Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell on Sunday said quote we
need to make sure the Children's Health
Insurance Program which is expiring gets
to panel before the end of the year
sound that people are wasting time on
tax cuts these two issues are completely
disconnected the tax cuts have nothing
to do with chip nothing but Kimmel is
trying to promote a narrative that isn't
even true and he's using his son to do
it which is just yucky okay it's just
gross the fact is again tax cuts have
nothing these are two completely
separate legislative efforts and not
only are they completely separate
legislative efforts what's hilarious
about this is the Kimmel is saying that
the Republicans are trying to hold up
chip because they're trying to help out
their millionaire and billionaire
friends they're taking money from kids
like Jimmy Kimmel Sonic's captive Jimmy
Kimmel some rapport and they're trying
to use that money to pay off all of
these super wealthy people you know
where the Republicans are trying to get
the money to pay for chip you want know
what they're trying get the money to pay
for chip where the offsets are for
high-income earners on Medicare in other
words they're trying to get it from rich
old people they're trying to take the
money from rich old people and make sure
young sick kids can get it and Jimmy
Kimmel is sitting there ripping on the
Republicans for it now again the point
of this is that optics and politics
means everything optics and politics is
the whole shebang and the fact that he
is willing to use his child for opticals
for optics like this I find it really
distasteful I think it's bad for the
country I think again that it drives us
to a place in politics where we can't
have conversations with one another
because if I say if I didn't have a kid
who had a condition would I be able to
critique Jimmy Kimmel when people pay
attention to it or if I were just
another conservative commentator if I
revoke Roe right who's not even
particularly concerned about all things
healthcare let's say our avec Roy and I
don't know I don't think I because he
has had a kid with a condition like this
but let's say that you're a full-on
expert in healthcare this is what you
did full-time right you worked over at
Cato Institute or at Heritage Foundation
and there's what you did full-time you
don't have a sick kid we're not gonna
pay as much attention to you as we do to
Jimmy Kimmel because Jimmy Kimmel has a
child who's who's playing with his thumb
while he talks I hate this stuff more
than I can tell you I think it's
opportunistic I think Jimmy Kimmel is
doing something morally bad here I think
it is morally bad to use your child's
condition as a as a lever in order to
promote your favorite policies
especially when your child's condition
has nothing to do with those policies
policy is about what's good for the bulk
of the American people it is not about
what sympathy level you can garner by
bringing out a cute child or a cute
puppy to me these this argument is no
different than if Nancy Pelosi would
start stumping for Obamacare and she'd
bring out a cute puppy and Stroke it
while she was talking and then every so
often referenced the puppy again not
because puppies and children are the
same I'm violently against this notion
right whenever people say that they have
a dog and it's their four-legged child I
just want to kind of kick them in the
ass but what is it but is what is
particularly ridiculous about this is
again the notion that Jimmy Kimmel what
he's saying is factually wrong but
somehow it's given added credibility and
if you look at the headlines today about
Jimmy Kimmel I'm gonna tell you what
some of the headlines say right on on
various outlets so USA Today joined by
his son Billy an emotional Jimmy Kimmel
makes the case for chip TV when Jimmy
Kimmel brings son to live for chip
funding plea daily beats Jimmy Kimmel
with son until delivery tear-filled
tear-filled plea for health insurance
Jimmy Kimmel and Billy blast Congress
for holding chip hostage according to
Deadline
Jimmy Kimmel brings out his son to talk
about how
okay at any point in here would somebody
like to point out the fact that
everything Jimmy Kimmel says about this
thing is actually not true like would
that be useful at any point do you
actually talk about the facts of the
situation are we just gonna be
bamboozled by the fact that he's
bringing out a cute kid again I can
bring out cute kids too
I'm not sure you'd make the show more
visually interesting if I were to have
my son and daughter on my knees while I
did it I just don't think that it adds
the political points I'm making very
much and I think it would be a cheap
political trick we have known for years
that politicians kissing babies is a
cheap political trick it is no less
cheap when a late night host brings out
his own baby in order to push a message
that has nothing to do with reality
okay so meanwhile today is the big day
in Alabama voters are heading to the
polls to choose between a pro-abortion
fanatic Tom Jones and an alleged child
molester Roy Moore so all the best of
America on display in Alabama today Roy
Moore apparently rode up to the polls on
a horse because we just have to signal
the cowboy and vest and cowboy hat I
really want someone to go back and score
in the score from gunfight at the OK
Corral with Kirk Douglas I think it'd
just be great okay Corral like we met we
may as well just go full-on here and the
closing pitch for more was interesting
to say the least
Steve banned and made the closing pitch
for Roy Moore he ripped into Joe
Scarborough he mocked joe scarborough's
college education he apparently said
that he got into better schools than joe
could have Georgetown and Harvard
there's only one problem with this line
of attack Joe Scarborough won to wait
for it University of Alabama yeah so
then I love Steve Benton jet-setting in
from Los Angeles I think the schmucky is
jet-setting in from Los Angeles
outsiders could not have any impact on
this race Steve Bannon from Harvard
Business School and Los Angeles and
Goldman Sachs and Joe Scarborough cannot
listen I'm not a huge Joe Scarborough
fan I've hit Joe on this program a
number of times but I'm Jones to the
University of Alabama dude and then
another speaker at the at the more of an
troll told a story that was supposed to
show how moral Roy Moore was it was
weird it was weird
the story is here it's the echos pretty
bad here one of Romans old Vietnam buddy
says that when they were in Vietnam
together they somehow stumbled into a
brothel they're a bunch of underage
girls there and Roy Moore too said let's
get out of here and this is the
exonerating tale for Roy Moore first of
all I would just say that I wasn't in
Vietnam so I don't know how often you
just sort of stumbled into a brothel but
beyond that weird story weird story and
then it got weirder so I'm gonna play
you audio of Roy Moore's wife who is
trying to rebut allegations that Moore
is an sematic I'm not sure who made the
allegations that Moore's anti-semitic
because I haven't seen a lot of
rationale for that allegation the only
odd semantic thing I saw in this Alabama
race was the attempt by somebody who's
allied with more I guess to put out robo
calls suggesting that there was a Jewish
Washington Post reporter Bernie
Bernstein who is calling around and
trying to pay people to tell tales about
Roy Moore that was pretty bad but I'm
gonna play you another weird piece of
audio we basically entered the twilight
zone in this race and thankfully it's
gonna come to an end by tonight we'll
find out whether Moore is the senator or
whether he's not first I want to say
thank you to our sponsor is over at
legacy box so the holidays are upon you
if you want to make you want to get a
fantastic gift for your parents like
this one makes a great gift for you and
your parents legacy box is this so what
legacy box does is it preserves your
memory basically you load legacy box
with your old tapes fill them pictures
audio recordings and you send it to them
they will get them back to you in a
couple of weeks on DVD or a convenient
thumb drive so all of those films that
are out there in the garage just
moldering
rotting all of those all of those VHS
tapes that you're never gonna be able to
use because you don't have VHS player
anymore you send those owns a legacy box
they send it back to you on a DVD or on
the thumb drive you don't have to worry
about getting those waterlogged boxes
out of the house if some sort of natural
disaster occurs or if you're moving and
said just grab your thumb driving you're
ready to go it makes all of those
memories accessible it means you're
gonna watch them more often it means are
gonna enjoy them more often it is a
fantastic gift for Christmas
particularly legacy box take care of it
takes care of everything and they
provide updates at every step of the
process over a quarter-million families
have used them for a limited time go to
legacy box comm slash Ben and you get
40% discount on your order that's legacy
box comm slash Ben legacy box comm slash
Ben again I think this makes a fantastic
gift one of the things I've said over
and over again is that preserving those
memories is one of the more important
things you can do in life because your
brain is not going to retain all of that
but you being able to go back and look
at the tape you being able to go back
and enjoy what it was like with your
parents 30 years ago is an amazing
amazing experience
legacy box.com makes that real go to
legacy box comm slash Ben get 40%
discount on your order remember to use
the slash pen so they know that we sent
you okay so this was the clip that had
the media agog last night
Roy Moore's wife Caleb she was trying to
her about allegations that were way more
was an anti-semite again I'm not sure
who made those allegations I guess there
were some people who had made those
allegations with regard to something
having to do with George Soros he made a
comment about George Soros going to hell
which may very well happen I'm not sure
what that had to do with Soros being
Jewish per se Soros is not exactly an
Orthodox Jew in any case here is Kayla
Moore making a very weird reference
might tell you all this because I've
seen the record straight while they're
here
[Applause]
one of our attorneys is a Jew
and she smiles and she looks into the
camera and you kind of nods okay she
should have started with that one right
we have close friends who are rabbis and
Jewish then we fellowship with them that
would be the best place to start not we
have a lawyer who's a Jew yeah welcome
to America
okay everyone has a lawyer who's a Jew
or an accountant or a doctor right it
turns it like not not a particularly
strong defense there but this entire
race has been weird doesn't mean they're
anti-semitic no everybody who's going
off on that last night on Twitter you're
just being silly okay Kayla Moore may
have gotten that out of order maybe she
shouldn't have said her lawyer was a Jew
as a defense because it's dumb defense
and anti-semitism if it in fact existed
but putting all of that aside no I don't
think that there's a lot of proof that
Moore is anti-semitic I think there are
plenty of other reasons not to vote for
Roy Moore among them credible
allegations of child molestation but now
we are down to the wire in Alabama
President Trump he's really ramping up
his support for Roy Moore he's
attempting to get Roy Moore over the
finish line if Roy Moore were to lose
after Trump has signed off on this it
would be pretty devastating to Trump
particularly would show that he doesn't
have a lot of coattails it would show
that he probably should have stayed out
of it in the first place like this was
actually a safe position for him if he
had just stayed out of it there's a good
case to be made that he is safest
politically what Trump is safest
politically if he stays out of this now
for Roy Moore wins then Trump gets to
own Roy Moore so I'm not sure that's
much of a booby prize I mean what a
parting gift that is right you win and
now you are stapled to the guy who's
probably gonna be put up before a Senate
Ethics Committee investigation for
possible child molestation when is a
younger man none of this is good either
way this goes bad for Republicans if you
have more wins Republicans gets Hanser
questions about Roy Moore until the end
of time and Roy Moore is not a guy whose
mouth shut he's gonna say a lot of dumb
stuff if we're more losses then
Republicans lose the seat to Doug Jones
so well done primary voters and well
done Roy Moore who wouldn't step out in
the first place it does show you
shamelessness will get you everywhere in
politics if he had any sense of shame he
would have stepped out during this
election cycle he has none and that
benefits politicians I will say it
benefits politicians not to have any
serious sense of shame okay so now I
want to turn to the Democrat attempts to
oust president Trump so they've used the
Al Franken quasi resignation
Franken still hasn't set a date for
leaving they've used this as an excuse
to go after president Trump they're
using the the sexual allegations against
remor as a lever to go up against
President Trump now all the Democrats
are saying that President Trump should
step down and yesterday I talked sort of
briefly about whether Trump should
quote-unquote resign over allegations of
sexual abuse and this brought me I was
trying to think about this in a more
systematic way last night
I was trying to figure out you know when
should politicians in general resign and
it seems to me that there are five
different options as to when politicians
should resign this is not when
politicians do resign this is when
politicians could or should resign so
answer number one is never politicians
should never resign unless they are
dragged away in Chains they should never
resign they were elected by the people
there's no excuse for them resigning
unless there is due process and they're
convicted in a court of law
they should never ever ever resign this
seems to be the way that Roy Moore is
going about it or Trump or Bill Clinton
or most politicians who have a
generalized lack of shame is the way
that they deal with allegations is
simple by saying listen there's no bid
no due process I deny the allegations
utterly I'm not leaving right this is
actually in some ways the most clear-cut
standard that we're never gonna pressure
a politician to resign or that a
politician shouldn't resign unless the
politician has actually been convicted
of a crime and this makes a certain
amount of sense but it means that you're
gonna have to say the Democrats it's
okay for Bob Menendez to sit in the
Senate in the same way it's fine for Roy
Moore to sit in the Senate okay option
number two is you're only supposed to
resign when you're about to be convicted
of something so we're in the final
stages there's been a criminal
prosecution Bob Menendez is on trial is
he gonna be convicted or not he should
resign now because it's not good for
convicted felons to be sitting in the
United States Senate even for five
minutes as standard number two so in
this case Roy Moore
there's been no prosecution against him
it's he's not about to be convicted of
anything sort of the Richard Nixon
strategy is about to be impeached or
convicted so now it is time for him to
and now it's time for him to step down
that's standard number two and again
relatively clear-cut standard but most
politicians are not gonna hold by it
number three is before an election so
bad allegations come out before an
election sure the politicians step down
typically politicians have the reason
the politicians typically have is
because politicians don't want to sell
you their party with the allegations but
again if you have no shame then you
stick around so that's that standard
number three before an election you step
down because you don't want to force the
voters to choose
between somebody about whom there are
credible allegations of bad behavior and
somebody who does not have those
allegations but whom you disagree with
you want to avoid the more Jones race
more should have stepped down earlier in
this race option number four is when new
information arises about something
horrible you did post elections this is
the Al Franken scenario so nobody knew
about this stuff that Al Franken's it
before the election and when he was
elected in in 2010 or 2012 rather and
when Al Franken let's see Franklin was
2010 I believe so yeah it's when when he
was first elected in that special
election these allegations were not out
the allegations came out afterward new
information means he should re-evaluate
himself and he should resign and then
finally there's the only standard by
which Democrats could credibly argue the
Trump should step down and that is when
he's done something horrible at all so
we find out that 30 years ago now we
find out we knew that 30 years ago you
did really bad stuff and we knew that
during the election cycle but now we're
gonna call on you to resign visit the
reason I'm making these distinctions is
because I was trying last night to
figure out what's the difference between
Al Franken and Trump now the easy answer
is there is no difference between Al
Franken and Trump but I don't think
that's exactly correct
there may be very little difference in
the allegations but there is a
difference in the timing all of the
allegations about Trump came out before
November Trump was then greenlit by the
American people now could there be an
impeachment over this sort of activity
sure he could have an impeachment over
anything it's a political crime but the
idea that you're gonna treat pressure to
push Trump to resign in the same way you
treat Franken is weird considering that
the American people knew about every
single allegation that's currently being
aired about Trump before the election
cycle and they greenlit him that's a
different thing than Franken resigning
because none of his voters knew about
any of these allegations when they agree
and let him new evidence means that
Franken could step down and spare his
party the the heartache of running for
re-election we already know what Trump
is we already know what the allegations
against Trump were so mumping in Trump
and Franken together I think is
logically incorrect so before I go any
further here I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at MVM tea so I
can attest to the quality of MVM tea
watches first of all they look great so
here is my new MVM tea watch it is just
a spectacular looking watch looks like a
300 400 dollar watch this thing was like
130 140 dollars now that's the general
price range for movement watches they
run anywhere from $95 I just there's so
good that I just bought two for the
holidays I bought one for my wife I
bought one for my mom
so I hope my mom does not listen to the
show because it's a surprise but the but
the that MDM see watches are
high-quality they look really good
my wife likes it likes the watch this is
her second MV MT watch she liked the
first one so much that I'm getting her a
second one because they're so nice MV MT
watches again started 95 bucks may be
much more expensive at a department
store because they've cut out the
middleman they're classic design quality
construction they're really minimalist
they're really clean looking I love them
they're very versatile as well as I've
told you my son beats the living snot
out of this watch and it looks just as
good as the day that I bought it it
really is an amazing watch I was
devastated when when we lost the watch
for about two weeks and I couldn't find
it it turned out my son liked it so much
he stuffed it in his car seat this is
the second MV MC watching his stuffed in
his cars and I couldn't find for a week
so he also like seven BMC watches
everyone does they're making gift-giving
even easier when you go to mV MT calm /
appear oh you can buy any watch starting
at $95 and get a free strap all place in
an elegant gift box ready to give
shipping is free so go to mV mt comm /
shapiro make sure you use the / compare
so you get that special deal again you
get a free strap all place in an elegant
gift box if somebody doesn't like it
returns are free but you won't need it
because they really look good MVM t.com
/ shapiro remember to use that / up
arrow so that they know that we sent you
and you get that free strap and the
elegant gift box as well MVM t-dot-com /
shapiro go check it out ok so meanwhile
the the democrats have turned to the
sexual harassment allegations with
regard to president Trump specifically
because they are I think trying to move
away from the allegations with regard to
Russia those are panning out into
nothing I mean those have really turned
into just a big nothing Victor Davis
Hanson has a very good piece over at
National Review now Hansen is much more
of a supporter of President Trump than I
am obviously but he has a very good
rundown about all the problems with
special councilor Muller's investigation
he talks about all of the various
members of the investigation who have
been in weird positions he starts with
the Comey the James Comey subordinate
Deputy Director of the FBI Andrew McCabe
around the Washington DC office that was
involved in the Clinton email
investigations he did not recuse himself
from the email investigations until one
week before the presidential election
even though his wife was running for a
Democrat Senate seat in Virginia and
seems a huge donation of almost $700,000
from the Clinton organization basically
and then it turns out that at least six
of Moeller staff of 15 lawyers had given
to Hillary Clinton okay
you know that's not dispositive a lot of
people did get money to Hillary Clinton
but then there's Peter stroszek I don't
go to Peter stroke right an FBI
investigator assigned to the Muller
investigation with of Russian collusion
according to Victor Davis Hanson stroke
and Lisa page a consulting FBI lawyer or
for some reason relieved from the
investigation of Trump in late summer
2017 Muller's office refused to explain
the departure of either other than to
let the media assume that the departures
were unrelated and due to normal
revolving or transient appointments okay
and then we learned that they were
having an extramarital affair and had
been sending anti-trump text messages
and then we found out that Andrew
Weissman who is another veteran
prosecutor who's been assigned to
Muller's legal team praise Sally Yates
you remember Sally Yates
she was the administration holdover the
Obama holdover from the DOJ who'd broken
her oath of office and refused to carry
out Trump's administra immigration order
and Andrew Weissman who's been working
on the mobile legal team he wrote to
Sally Yates I'm so proud and in awe and
that came out and then we found out
another attorney on the mother staff
Jeanne Reed was at one time the personal
attorney for Ben Rhodes the fiction
writer turned Obama national security
adviser who's a garbage heap of a human
being when it comes to his policy and
his political opinions and then it turns
out so I mean the list goes on and on
that a senior Justice Department
official bruised or connected with
various ongoing investigations under the
aegis of the Justice Department and was
reassigned for his contact with the
opposition research firm responsible for
the Clinton funded anti-trump dossier
which in theory could have been the
catalyst for the original investigation
of collusion by the FBI it turns out
that his wife Nellie or whose
experiences Russian politics and history
actually worked for fusion GPS during
the 2016 campaign her husband was
working apparently on the Russia
investigation and then we found out that
there's a guy named Aaron Zeb Lee who
served as Muller's chief of staff while
at the FBI and was assigned to the FBI's
counterterrorism division in the
National Security Division at the DOJ
and he served as assistant US attorney
in the national security and terrorism
unit in Virginia but he represented a
guy named Justin Cooper who is the IT
staffer who set up Hillary's illegal and
unsecure server at her home so basically
half the people who are involved the
mobile investigation have been
compromised in some way or another by
connections with Hillary Clinton or
opposition to President Trump this is
bad stuff right this is bad stuff and
it's one of the reasons why President
Trump is now being rumored to be
thinking of opening up a special counsel
investigation into the Special Counsel
investigation that's how far we've gone
so we are now at the point where it's
like dr. Seuss you know the places
you'll go there's a bee watcher and then
you he's not doing his job so you have
the bee watcher watcher who watches the
bee watcher
but it turns out he's lazy toys you have
the bee watcher watcher until the entire
town of hototc is on a bee watcher watch
her and watch her and watch right then
that's basically we're gonna have
special investigations with a special
investigator all the way down the line
Turtles all the way down very exciting
stuff I can't believe the Moller botched
the investigation as badly or maybe I
can maybe I can but that's the reason
why Democrats are now turning to the
sexual accusations about President Trump
the reason that they are doing so is
because obviously they think the Russian
investigation is beginning to fall apart
it's the reason why Kristen Gillibrand
is going after Trump Trump by the way
fighting back against Kirsten Gillibrand
today I don't know this is one of those
cases again where I just wish Trump
would shut the hell up on Twitter it's
so stupid what he's doing Kirsten
Gillibrand is going after him for all of
the for all of the sexual harassment
allegations from last year remember
Kirsten Gillibrand was best friends with
the Clintons until five minutes ago when
she decided it would be more useful to
throw their bodies under the bus Kirsten
Gillibrand received money from from
Trump when Trump was just a big Democrat
donor and now Kristin Gillibrand was
ripping on Trump and she says that we
need to investigate Trump here's what
she had to say and an unprecedented time
in American politics and the world is
gripped by this saga I mean here it now
takes aimed squarely at president Trump
as this whole me - movement you know
gains momentum should he shred the White
House be worried well president Trump
should resign these allegations are
credible they are numerous I've heard
these women's testimony and many of them
are heartbreaking
and President Trump should resign his
position okay so she says that there
should be a full investigation so Trump
tweets back at her and here's what Trump
tweets is 18 so Trump Trump goes
directly at her lightweight senator
Kirsten Gillibrand so it late
as one of his favorite again Trump only
has a lexicon of about seven insults and
he just rotates them so it's lightweight
senator Kirsten Gillibrand a total
flunky for Chuck Schumer and someone who
could come to my office begging again in
scare quotes for no reason for campaign
contributions not so long ago and would
do anything for them is now in ring
fighting against Trump very disloyal to
Bill and crooked you sed I don't know
used okay I thought those yes for a
second I thought that was the US
Department of Education that used
because of the random random capitals
all of this the sin tab put in putting
the crazy syntax of the sweet Assad and
the fact that it's barely written in
English the fact that he's going after
Kirsten Gillibrand is very stupid okay
the reason that it's stupid is because
why would you possibly raise her profile
this way Kristen Gillibrand wants to run
for president in 2020 this is an in-kind
contribution to senator Kirsten
Gillibrand she could not hope for a
better she of course comes out and
strikes back at trump and suggests that
President Trump is bullying her and then
this is what drives me not the entire
media suggests that Trump sexually
harassed Kirsten Gillibrand in this
tweet guys that's not what sexual
harassment means being mean to a woman
online is not sexual harassment sexual
harassment is acting in a sexually
inappropriate way toward a woman saying
that she's dumb or that she's corrupt
that is not a thing president Trump says
that about everyone like there there are
five people left in the United States he
hasn't said that about most of them work
for the administration the idea that the
maybe I mean he's head said half of his
administration is dumb in corrupt like I
don't understand why this even comes
close to looking like sexual harassment
in any real way but the President of the
United States is lifting Kirsten
Gillibrand profile Elizabeth Warren who
again a highly overrated intellect I
love the fact that Elizabeth Warren then
tweeted out that Trump had slut-shamed
her in the suite she tweeted are you
really trying to bully intimidate and
shame senator you're senator
gillibrand do you know who you're
picking a fight with good luck with that
President Trump
nevertheless hashtags she persisted oh
my god all these people need to go away
just go away
is it Christmas yet can we just take the
time off like please Elizabeth Warren
its Foca hunt is right now poke on Foca
honza's photo honza's where exactly did
Trump slut-shame senator gillibrand
there does she even know it shame
slut-shaming is to say to a woman that
she is somehow morally less because she
sexually promiscuous there's always a
weird insult in in my and it was always
a weird critique in my view today
quote-unquote slut-shaming somebody I
wasn't aware that being more of that
being sexually promiscuous was it was a
net positive but in any case this is now
that the line the Democrats are going to
use that Trump is sexually harassing
kirsten gillibrand oh the level of
stupid
oh the in the same level of insane
stupid and Trump didn't need to get into
this it's a waste of time
you should have just ignored it it was
gonna go away everybody was gonna know
that this was driven by politics more
than it was by policy or by reality but
that's the way that it goes okay so
before I go any further I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Dollar Shave Club so you've heard me
talk about the terrific shave I get
right here under my chinny chin chin
according to Jewish law for my Dollar
Shave Club razor especially when I use
it with the dr. Carver shea butter I'm
here to tell you I'm not gonna give up
my membership in fact I am adding more
daily products to my routine the Dollar
Shave Club makes products for your hair
face skin shower everything you need I
mean if you wonder how I look and smell
so great I know that you can't smell me
but I mean if you could you would just
be blown away it's incredible it's all
of their own original stuff it's the
Dollar Shave Club materials these only
the finest premium ingredients they
deliver it to you just like they do
their razors you never have to worry
about going to the store again for your
body wash or for your or for your skin
care stuff means no more annoying trips
to the store I use Dollar Shave Club for
just about everything they're covering
people from head-to-toe and with gift
memberships an e-card
gift cards available it makes for a
great Christmas gift as well they can
help cover the names on your holiday
shopping list I want you to love Dollar
Shave Club as much as I do I have
arranged for you to try your first month
of their best razor along with travel
sized versions of their shave butter
body cleanser and yes even the fabled
butt wipes for just five dollars after
that replacement cartridges ship for
just a few dollars a month it is the DSC
starter set get yours for just five
bucks exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
slash pen that's dollarshaveclub.com
slash pen again and get the travel
versions of the shea butter the body
cleanser the butt wipes for five bucks
and then replacement cartridges ship for
just a few bucks a month check it out at
dollarshaveclub.com slash bend that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash been okay so
III do have to I do have to tell you
about this insane piece from everyday
just because it is HIGHlarious okay so
this piece from everyday feminism
discusses what intersectional feminist
are looking for in a date it is not a
wonder that they are miserable people
intersectional feminist because these
are questions they're ten questions you
are supposed to ask your date if you're
an intersectional feminist the following
list of questions writes who wrote this
letter awit I'm not going to assume
his/her gender I'm not going to assume
gender because we're not allowed to do
that at everyday feminism the greatest
site on the internet but here is what
Laura writes the following list of
questions is applicable to all
relationships certainly not just
cisgender heterosexual ones one do you
believe the black lives matter well
there's a hell of an opener you sit down
for a date and before you even start
talking the woman says to you do you
believe that black lives matter like how
are you supposed to answer that what
happens you say no I mean like what
first of all like does anyone the United
States say no to that question of course
everyone believes black lives matter the
question is whether you think the
movement is actually worthwhile or
whether it is a vast misinterpretation
of variable data on police activity but
never mind all that
it's just then what are your thoughts on
gender and sexual orientation I love
this the gender binary is a tiny box I
wish it didn't exist but it does I
wouldn't want to be with anyone who's
queer phobic is that your that that's
like your opener then that's it that's
another one your opening questions is
like you're a straight woman and you're
dating a straight guy and your first
question is would you have sex with the
dude or are you queer phobic like are
you do you believe that I'm a woman okay
how do you work to dismantle sexism and
misogyny in your life what are you
talking about to me I'm just a plumber
like what are you like what does I met
cisgender heterosexual I'm not having
there toxic masculinity questions are
threatened in any way and they love us
as a monolith they love a women have to
offer whether it's sex food love care
emotional labor they love us for what we
can do for them not because of who we
are for ourselves well I feel like this
is sort of a weird arbitrary boundary
that you're drawing here it seems to me
that what you are is very much related
to what you do so that's the that's sort
of a weird take on things what are your
thought on sex work like that this one
my favorites what are your thoughts on
sex work really the
sectional feminists want you to ask your
your date what your thoughts are on
prostitution hint to the ladies if you
say to a man what are your thoughts on
prostitution the guys like love it all
for it
it shouldn't date him it's gonna go
badly but apparently this is a question
to ask when you're dating because
because being pro sex worker is a
necessary pillar for dismantling the
patriarchy there's nothing that
dismantles the patriarchy like making it
more available for scummy men's and have
sex for money no nothing dismantles the
patriarchy just like that which is why
when you watch old westerns everyone
goes to the whorehouse because they're
all trying to dismantle the patriarchy
it's a thing are you a supporter of the
BDS movement perfectly I love this I
love this it's just great that on your
first date you should ask whether you
hate Jews and wants to divest from
Israel what is your understanding of
settler colonialism and indigenous
rights Wow
do you think capitalism is exploitative
first of all I would say yes to that
question just so that I could avoid
actually having to pay for dinner I
would say capitalism is exploitative so
let's let's break the check can any
human be illegal
do you support Muslim Americans and
non-muslim people from Islamic countries
and does your ally Shipp include
disabled folks if a woman asked me any
of these questions run as fast as you
possibly can because that's horrifying
that'll be the worst marriage ever but I
guess marriage is to shed anyway so who
cares all right so before we go any
further here and there is much more to
come I first have to say that you need
to go over and subscribe so that's for
me to say right now
so 9900 but we'll get you a subscription
to daily wire.com and today's a good day
to get that subscription why because you
can be part of our fourth episode of the
conversation it is coming up today 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific featuring
your favorite person ever your favorite
president ever Donald's right now
favorite person ever me subscribe today
be a part of the conversation and ask me
questions and I will mock you or I will
answer them or I'll mock you and then
answer them or answer them and then mock
you you just never know that's that's
the fun part of it my conversation will
stream live on the bench up here on
Facebook page and the daily where a
youtube channel will be free for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask the questions if you want to ask
questions go into our website daily wire
head over to the conversation page and
watch the live stream you can start
typing into the daily wired chat box I
will answer questions as they come in
for an entire hour once again subscribe
to get your questions answered by me ben
shapiro today 5
in eastern 2 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation you get that for $9.99 a
month also can be part of the mailbag on
Friday $9.99 a month you can be part of
Andrew clavin's mailbag in michael moses
mailbag and you can watch the rest of
their show live on video all of that for
$9.99 a month your annual subscription
comes along with this the very greatest
in all vessels for beverage the leftist
here is hot or cold tumbler world-famous
often imitated never duplicated it is
just I mean the joy that runs through
your body when you hold this tumbler in
your hand it's just inconceivable and
you'll never get to experience it you'll
die alone and unhappy unless you get
this tumbler as well as our annual
subscription for ninety nine dollars a
year if you just want to listen later to
the rest of the show head on over to
YouTube SoundCloud iTunes subscribe
daily warrior calm for your for your
annual subscription again we are the
largest fastest growing podcast in the
nation
okay so I'm gonna go right to some
things I like and some things that I
hate so things I like I want to start
with some Beethoven so I I said
yesterday I'd read a Beethoven biography
over the weekend really enjoyed the
biography and now I want to play for you
a little bit of Beethoven music that you
may not know it's sort of off the beaten
track a little bit so the only ones that
everybody knows are v his symphony and
his ninth symphony
some people know the sixth symphony from
Fantasia but there's a lot of Beethoven
music that people have missed because
they just don't follow it that closely
so Beethoven's opus 130 is one of his
string quartets and there's a movement
called the Cavatina in the middle of the
string quartet it is so well known to
sort of as feats that it was actually
placed on the permanent disc that was
sent with the Stars with the with the
the Voyager the the starship Voyager the
shuttle that we sent out into deep space
that we sent out a CD on that on that
shuttle it's actually a golden record so
in case the aliens find it and they want
to know what kind of music we listen to
we put on some crap and then we put on
some good stuff so the good stuff is
Beethoven and Mozart and Bach and this
Cavatina from his string quartet is is
part of it
the part that I've pulled here is not
actually the most melodic part but it is
one of the most heartbreaking parts in
music it's what happened is that
Beethoven was suffering with his nephew
he his life was really difficult
Beethoven and he had a big fight with
his brother died his brother's wife was
a national convicted criminal and he
seized the son away from his his
sister-in-law and he had the court
actually relocate the son with him and
so his nephew was sort of his surrogate
son it wasn't particularly good father
and his surrogate son had all sorts of
trouble and in the middle of that
trouble he wrote the string quartet and
there is a part where he actually writes
in the he actually writes in the notes
well it would be verklempt in in yiddish
but it's I'm very member what it is in
German it's it's I'll look up the word
in a second but in any case the point
here is that the violin is supposed to
sound like it's actually crying and it's
a good imitation of musical crying as
hell over here here it is the Cavatina
one of
from Beethoven's opus 130
[Music]
so then it goes into back into the
regular thing we should listen the
entire movement it really is beautiful
that that portion they're supposed to be
the sort of person sobbing struggling to
catch their breath it's the only thing
that Beethoven wrote where he said he
cried when he wrote it
it is his glorious music Beethoven is
just spectacular a lot of its late music
is so complex the grossa fugue which I
may or may not play on the program it's
it's so complex that I don't understand
it properly I really want to know some
more music theory before analyzing it it
was so complex that it's time people
called it repellent he actually lose the
it was the last movement of this
particular string quartet I believe and
he removed it from this string quartet
because people didn't understand it
hundred years later people were still
calling in modern music because it was
so sophisticated in the way that he'd
written it okay time for it some other
things I like so I have to give Sarah
Huckabee Sanders some credit the press
went after her yesterday and she went
directly back at them over inaccuracies
in their reporting and I'm on Sarah
Huckabee Sanders aside here here is what
the press secretary had to say mistakes
they should own up to them sometimes a
lot of times you don't there's a very
big difference between making honest
mistakes and purposefully misleading the
American people something that happens
regularly you can't say I'm not done
well you cannot say that it's an honest
mistake when you're purposely putting
out information that you know to be
false or when you're taking information
that hasn't been validated that hasn't
been offered any credibility and that
has been continually denied by a number
of people including people with direct
knowledge of an instance this is
something that I'm speaking about the
number of reports that have taken place
a couple of weeks I'm simply stating
that there should be a certain level of
responsibility in thank you really show
acts acosta as well she should Acosta is
one of the most repellant reporters
working at the White House okay time for
one thing I hate and then we will get to
a quick deconstructing the culture so
so here is today's thing I hate so my
wife and I were bored the other night
and we decided to grab a movie from
Netflix and to chill as they say as the
children say and and the movie that we
grabbed we had not seen in the theaters
it was guardians of the galaxy - volume
2 volume 2 guardians of the galaxy vol 2
this movie is hot garbage this movie is
just terrible which makes me sad I liked
guardians of the galaxy one it is a bad
movie okay it's not just a bad movie
it's atrociously insultingly bad this
movie got 83 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
which demonstrates - you do not trust
the critics when it comes to comic book
movies trust me and I never say - trust
me on things trust me when it comes to
comic book movies my taste is
significantly better than the average
critic on Rotten Tomatoes who don't what
the hell they're talking about this
movie is no better than Justice League
in fact in significant ways actually
worse than Justice League at least
Justice League has a couple of memorable
scenes there is nothing remotely
memorable about this film they somehow
blow having Kurt Russell in the film
which is just ridiculous I don't know
how you blow having Kurt Russell in the
film Kurt Russell is great in everything
go watch tombstone instead of watching
this you'll enjoy it much better it's a
bunch of CGI nonsense
the only thing that's even mildly
interesting or funny is David Bautista
he's a who is actually turning out to be
quite a screen presence he's the only
thing in the film that's that's even
remotely worth seeing the rest of the
film is just awful Bradley Cooper's part
is garbage the Chris Pratt turns into a
nonentity in this movie the CGI is
unwatchable it'll give you a headache I
can't express to you how much I just
liked this movie so here's a bit of the
preview so you too can see how it'll
show you sort of how you can turn a
really bad movie into an okay trailer
because that's basically the message of
this of this particular segment
the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulders now whatever you do
don't push this button because that will
set off the bomb immediately and we'll
all be dead
now repeat back what I just said okay so
this is the whole movie and it's it's
this is every funny bit in the movie in
the first 30 seconds of this trailer
it's just and and I'm sorry baby Groot
is just such a pandering play and say oh
well you need something to sell at the
CBS for a Christmas so baby Groot yeah
okay do not watch this film if you have
watched this film see if you can get a
refund if you can't get a refund see if
you can invent a time machine and go
back and take the two hours of your time
back and if you can't let me know
because I want it back okay I'm gonna
deconstruct the culture here very
briefly so I'm going to spoil two things
that are currently in theaters and/or on
Netflix so if you don't like spoilers
then this is the part between out for
the show and you come back tomorrow so
here is the here are the two things that
I'm gonna spoil I'm gonna spoil not
really but a little bit I'm gonna spoil
godless on Netflix and I'm gonna spoil
mud bound which is also available on
Netflix and in theaters right now
because they both make the same plot
mistake and it drives me up a wall so to
introduce why this is a mistake I want
to show you the scene from the classic
Western Shane so Shane if you haven't
seen it one of the great westerns of all
time just terrific Alan Ladd Van Heflin
Jean Arthur and the whole point here is
that Ellen Ladd is sort of a wandering
gunfighter it's basically the same plot
is godless he's basically a wandering
gunfighter who stumbles into a town
that's being dominated by bad people and
he is signed on as sort of a farmhand at
Van Heflin farm Van Heflin and Jean
Arthur are married they have a child ran
into wilds my believe won an honorary
Oscar for this film and they and an Alan
Ladd sort of becomes the boys hero he
sort of becomes the boys hair even
though the father is a good guy and the
mother starts falling in love with Alan
Ladd and that's the whole theme of the
film the whole theme of the film is Duty
outweighing your necessity to have
feelings basically hey you're you have
duties to do good things even when your
feelings would drive you in the other
direction it's a really good film it's
it's a little bit long but it holds up
so here is a scene in which you will see
Jean Arthur who plays the wife she Alan
Ladd has just gotten in a fight she at
both Alan Ladd and Van Heflin have
gotten in a fight over at the dry goods
store with some of the bad guys and
she is talking to Ellen lad and and you
can see she's falling in love with Alan
Ladd and her husband Van Heflin is sort
of watching this happen
yeah it needs a bandage it's good enough
Miriam it's fine thanks very much wanna
know something mother what is it
[Music]
do you I love them almost as much as I
love pop that's alright isn't it
he's a fine man he's so good yes I like
him too Jerry
people can't see Alan Ladd walks out of
the room and Jean Arthur comes out of
her kids room and she opens the door and
she's looking out after Shane and then
then half when her husband opens the
door okay so this is called subtlety
okay this is a thing that was completely
now lacked in movies it's so good right
I mean it's so good in the subtlety of
it right you know that she you know that
she has a thing for Alan Ladd you know
Alan Ladd has a thing for her and that
he's and that he's walking out because
he wants to preserve the family and
protect the family the reason he leaves
at the end is because he wants to
protect the family he's already saved
helped save the town he's already helped
clean in the town and now he has to
leave and the boy doesn't understand it
it's heartbreaking and it's wonderful at
the same time it's such a good film okay
now here's where I'm gonna spoil a
little thing about godless soin godless
basically there's a town of women and
the and all the men in the town of died
in a mining accident there's on the
first five minutes of the show and a
character exactly like Alan Ladd comes
to town right he you don't know his
background you know that he was sort of
a criminal but he comes to town and he
gets involved with Michelle Dockery who
you'll remember from Downton Abbey and
she had she also has a son and in
exactly the same way I mean it's exactly
the same plot okay to rip off and the an
ROI comes in and he's training the kid
he's training the kid to you know ride a
horse and he's training the kid how to
had a farm better and all this kind of
stuff and meanwhile the mother is sort
of falling in love with him now she's
not married right Michelle jaakor he's
not married but it's pretty clear that
there's another guy in the town who has
a crush on her and he's also a good guy
right he's a sheriff he's going blind
and he it turns out that that he has
known for a while and I won't spoil that
part of it but in any case and one of
the things that ends up happening is
that very much near the end of the show
near the end of the show she goes into
the barn and they have sex
okay this is paralleled in in the in
this movie mud bound in the movie mud
bound basically as I talked about on the
show Carey Mulligan is a woman who's
living with her husband in the down-home
south and her husband is kind of a slob
they have a couple of kids and her
husband's brother is the sort of
romantic pilot figure who has PTSD he
comes back to town and the two brothers
go up against one another because one of
them's racist in one of them isn't
basically and near the end of that movie
she has sex with the brother in both
cases let's just say that they end very
similarly to Shane okay in both cases
the you know the people don't end up
together right the people have sex don't
end up together and the reason that this
drives me up a wall is because of both
of those films would have been better
with a little more subtlety you actually
end up destroying the character of the
man by having him have sex with the
woman in those films but our modern
society cannot take the idea of two
people being in sexual tension without
there being consummation I can't take
that idea right that was the entire idea
of human virtue was the idea that you
can be tempted to do something and you
should not do it because it's immoral
and what makes you a good person is with
what withstanding the temptation to do
things that are immoral that's what
makes you a better person
not not consummating it and it's a
throwaway once you consummate it okay
the fact is that the godless would have
been significantly better if we never
consummate swith with the with the with
this woman because then it's he comes in
he helps the son and you know that he
wants to get together with her but he
also is not willing to stick around and
it's not kind to the woman and it's not
good for him for him to consummate this
relationship and then leave her to this
other guy like it's bad right that's
that's why Alan Ladd leaves he leaves in
shame because he wants this family to be
together because it's important for the
family to be together in in godless it's
exactly I mean it is down to the note
exactly the same plot and yet the guy
sleeps with the girl and it ruins it
it's not good it's not smart and it's
bad and it says something about modern
society and the same thing is true in my
band the exact they're trying to make a
hero out of the pilot who stands up
against racism as they haven't sleep
with his brother's wife one time and
then leave what the hell is the point of
that why would you do that it's only
because we as a society have decided
that self control is no longer a virtue
self-control is no longer something
worth prising and then you wonder what
about you know harassment of women you
seriously age a society that does not
prize and treasure and cherish and
burnish
self-control is a society that
incentivizes men not to take part in it
the ethics of shame are much better than
the ethics of godless and they're much
better than the ethics of mud bound and
it's also a better movie it's better art
because it's more true to what a good
man does a good man withholds his own
feelings when it means damaging other
people okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with the results of the big election in
Alabama which I'm sure will be
fascinating talk no matter which way it
goes I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jael para the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2017